hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video erster sorry dass die beleuchtung
bisschen dummes aber als es schon dunkel
draußen und das einzige leuchtmittel was
ich hier gerade habe ist mein iphone
dass ich einmal ein stativ mit tesafilm
angebracht habe ihr seht es schon im
titel und zwar die besten manager in
challenge es aber das ist so einen
challenge die eigentlich komplett
bescheuert ist ich meine die challenge
besteht daraus dass leute nichts tun
ja richtig gehört die challenge ist der
saison trennen der in amerika
aufgekommen ist mit seinem lied was
eigentlich im september schon raus
gekommen ist und überhaupt nicht gut
ankamen allerdings ist das sieht jetzt
irgendwie sinnbildlich für diese
challenge is wegen ist es gerade nachts
überall auf platz eins kann man machen
unglaublich viele leute haben diese
menschen stumm gemacht sei es
irgendwelche celebrity fing welche
fußballmannschaften djs oder ganz
normale leute einfach deswegen habe ich
mit den challenges rausgesucht die weko
wind und zeigt ihr euch nach die erste
mensch einen stich heute zeigen möchte
die wir besonders gut gefällt ist vor
dem portugiesischen fußball nationalteam
aufgenommen worden die komplette
nationalmannschaft von den wal halt nach
einem fußballspiel in der kabine
versammelt und alle haben irgendwelche
sachen gemacht sei es von wegen jaich
der eine warme handy damals gerade
massage bekommen die anderen saßen der
förderung
und am ende wurde der superstar vom team
also cristiano ronaldo in der welt ist
cristiano ronaldo weltfußballer ich
glaube der wird am ende auf jeden fall
geändert seiner typischen freistoß pose
steht und das bin ich euch jetzt mal ein
alles in einem ultra cool weil es glaube
ich das erste fußball team war dass
diese manager channel schwierig gemacht
hat die ist auch jetzt gerade nicht
heute hochgeladen worden sondern auch
schon ein zwei wochen alt find ich cool
das zweite video was ihr euch heute
zeige ist von dem dj justin blau und
zwar macht er halt idm musik und trap
und alles hat wo man im klub so richtig
zu abgeht quasi jedenfalls hat er halt
während eines gigs von ihrem klub
einfach mal mit kollegen sein handy
gegeben und er selber hat die musik war
sie leise gemacht deswegen war sie
nahezu ausgemacht man fast nichts mehr
gehört und dann hat der typ kreis mit
der kamera erst die leute gefilmt die da
oben auf der bühne standen und eine
untergegangene publikum das komplette
publikum etwa sie mitgemacht und alles
was sie so gerade gemacht haben haben
die quasi gerade sich so auch ein
geworden sich wie so eine
schaufensterpuppe verhalten
und dann hat blau-weiß gesagt so jo
street one und dann sind alle so hoch
gesprungen
der bietet gedroppt also das blende ich
euch jetzt auch noch mal ein diesel
magic windgeschwindigkeit extrem geil
willst du die erste idm dj challenge war
in bezug auf diese ganze sache die ich
wirklich entdeckt habe und dadurch die
komplette kraut mit gemacht also das war
nur hammergeil das dritte video was
jetzt zeigen werde ist von der
englischen fußball nationalmannschaft ja
schon die zweite fußball
nationalmannschaft die ich euch heute
zeige jedenfalls haben dies nicht so
gemacht wie das portugiesische
nationalteam und die haben sich einfach
in der kabine versammeln uns in das
ganze durch gegangen und danach das
einer gefällt und es ging vor lange und
so sondern die haben wirklich während
eines fußballspiels als sie gerade tor
geschossen haben hat der torschütze sich
einfach so hingestellt und dann auf drei
weitere spieler haben sich dann auch
noch kurzfristig gestellt und dann war
es wieder vorbei
das habe ich hier ein mit reingenommen
weil es nicht getrübt war und alles drum
hat sich weiterbewegt und nur die vier
wussten quasi so yao wir machen die
magic vincent raven tor machen die haben
tor gemacht und haben es halt dann
wirklich auch durchgezogen
die eventuell schon erkennen könnt ist
diese management challenge konnte ich
gerade schon den ersten ausschnitt
gezeigt habe in einem flugzeug
aufgenommen worden und zwar nicht in
irgend einem stinknormalen
passagierflugzeug wo sehr viele
passagiere reinpassen sondern ein dem
privatjet von hillary clinton oder wurde
altes kamerateam und ein paar
abgeordnete gezeigt wir gerade schon
gesehen habe und am ende der haltbar wie
der auf seiner gitarre spielen deswegen
weise halt gerade nicht spielen weil er
einen stillstand und hillary clinton die
neben ihm stand fand ich mega cool weil
man daran einfach so gesehen hat dass
diese challenge so um die welt gegangen
ist wenn sogar eine
präsidentschaftskandidatin der
vereinigten staaten von amerika
mitgemacht hat und nein zu dem zeitpunkt
nation nicht erfahren dass sie keine
präsidentin wird das ganze waren nämlich
sollen aufruf sage ich mal zu warten
also die stimme abzugeben weil am ende
wurde gesagt bei uns denn sylvie bei dem
management talent sondern bau zudem geht
nach draußen und fand ich auf jeden fall
auch sehr coolen diesmal ein anderer
wahlwerbespot sag ich mal die nächste
menowin challenge die ich euch jetzt
zeigen werde
ist keine krasse challenge also das sind
jetzt nicht unglaublich viele leute im
klub involviert die beispielsweise dass
bei dem die dekra das ist jetzt kein
fußball-team das irgendwie im spiel
gerade ein tor geschossen hat und dann
einfach so viele leute ganz spontan
sagen your majesty management sondern es
ist ein fail also wieso klingelten jetzt
die haustür ich meinen guckt euch
einfach an ich bleibe immer ein
da denkst du was schön so ein challenge
video und dann rappelt sich der hund
einfach durch ist stark wir hatten ja
bisher schon sportmannschaften die die
männer können challenge gemacht haben
und wir hatten auch schon enorm viele
leute die meldung von challenge gemacht
haben wie beispielsweise bei den idee
gerade wir hatten aber weil es noch
nicht in kombination also eine
sportmannschaft mit dem kompletten
publikum sag ich mal deswegen habe ich
auf jeden fall auch noch mit
reingenommen die größte meine green
challenge australiens und zwar waren
dort drei 10.000 leute bei einem
basketballspiel war es glaube ich und
alle bis auf so ein paar
sicherheitsbeamten sich natürlich
bewegen müssen
bei dieser menge quatsch mit gemacht
also sei es die kinder die gerade auf
dem platz waren uns sich da irgendwie
aufwärmen durften oder sei es die leute
die wirklich auf der tribüne saßen oder
die kommentatoren und moderatoren die
unten vor der kamera standen
das ganze video gehen ultralange ich mag
euch einfach mal vier ausschüsse jetzt
die kurz hintereinander so dass ihr seht
worum es da geht
bei der hilfs managern challenge liegt
eine frau im bett mit einem anderen mann
dieser mann ist allerdings welche freuen
sondern sie geht gerade fremd und ihr
eigentlicher freundin kommt gerade die
tür rein und in der nächsten szene sieht
man dann halt wie dieser typ der gerade
noch mit ihrem bett lag versucht über
den balkon abzuhauen und ihr freund
kommt dann als reine hat seine knarre in
der hand
am ende ist es sei quasi so dass der typ
der mit der frau im bett lag sich in
einem schrank versteckt während die frau
mit ihrem wirklichen freund im bett
liegt also fange ich auf jeden fall ganz
cool weil ich mit reinem weiß zu diesem
mini challenge verbunden mit einer story
war das nächste video ist aus einer bar
irgendwo in großbritannien und zwar wird
dort gezeigt wieso das barleben abläuft
also als wenn man wirklich in einer wahl
so alles serie typen versammelt hätte
und alle bewegen sich einfach nichts
also das waren gerade quasi drei leute
die einfach an der basis und dann noch
halt die leute die wirklich hinter der
bearbeitung alle so gezapft haben aber
man sieht auch noch typischer andere
kundschaft nämlich gleich in der
nächsten sendung seht ihr noch mädels
die geraten foto machen und einen typen
einem anderen gerade ein stuhl weg zieht
kann ich einfach cool weil so alles
bedient wurde also da bewegliche bar
gezeigt und die leute die da zum trinken
sind die leute arbeiten leute wieder
späßchen man die leute wieder fotos
machen also alle leute die irgendwie mit
eingebunden worden
das hier ist die management challenge
von cassidy und jake also das sind der
bekannte englische youtuber und die
waren irgendwie auf tour um ihre neue
dvd bzw sie ihren neuen film
vorzustellen und die waren halt gerade
in jedem theater und haben halt war es
ihre show gemacht und haben nicht einmal
einen leuten gesagt so jetzt macht mal
still und sei ruhig und das halte ich
folge meiner wie ich das gerade sagen
jedenfalls haben sie halt die magic
world challenge gemacht und es waren
halt einerseits wieder voll viele leute
mit dabei die wirklich alle ruhig
gehalten haben und andererseits weil
youtuber die ultra feier also deswegen
habe ich die auf jeden fall mit
reingenommen diese challenge kommen wir
nun zu einer management change die ich
so wirklich kein zweites mal bisher
gesehen haben und zwar ist diese unter
wasser aufgenommen worden
ja unter wasser
die ganze leute wieder unter wasser
still gehalten haben sind glaube ich
teil von sommer unter wasser handball
rugby team sport wenn man sieht auf
jeden fall jetzt in der nächsten
einblendung auch noch dass dort eine
frau im tor liegt ich als jemand der
unter wasser nicht so lange die luft
anhalten kann findet das schon echt also
ich hab da schon respekt vor unter
wasser alter das was ihr vom video meine
da von herrn ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen etwas getan hat las man fett
lag da und bei 400 millionen like wow da
passiert gar nichts alter nach wie ihr
seht hier ein smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren wäre ultra cool weil ich dann
halt neuen abonnenten haben
dieser teil von mir also nicht von mir
sondern von meinem abonnenten aber das
ist irgendwie irgendwas lover ich
eigentlich hier findet ihr video
eingeblendet wo ich euch die dünnsten
bauwerke vorgestellt haben